[Music]
um
this is hadley wickham and take it away
thanks mara so i wanted to talk
not about visualization unfortunately uh
but about
a little bit about the tidy verse
generally
so i wanted to give you kind of a little
little bit of an update like kind of you
know where things are going in the tidal
verse where are we today
talk a little bit about tidy eval which
i know has
caused some unhappiness in various
places in our community
and then talk a little bit about what
we're doing to address some of those
problems in the future
so i made a few plots um to kind of show
how things are going so the first one is
just the cumulative number
of uh package downloads
so 2018 on the left 2019 on the right
uh i you know this this data is not
super trustworthy i don't i would love
to believe that you know three quarters
of a million people decided to use the
tidy verse
uh i guess basically on my birthday
um but i think the main takeaway here
is that you know the numbers are
continuing to grow really
just um continues to amaze me how many
people find these tools useful
the other thing that i think is really
fascinating is that 2019
was the first year that more people
downloaded d-player than ggplot2
i don't really know what that means but
i think that that's kind of interesting
so who who works on these packages so my
team at our studio
encompasses a bunch of people uh so jim
hester
thomason peterson gabochadi raman
francois
jenny bryan max [ __ ] lionel henry
me mara evereck and davis form
and very very soon we'll be joined by uh
julia silgi on monday
but as well as us there's also a huge
number of people in the community who
contribute to the tidy verse
and last year in fact we had 236 unique
contributors
which is just so amazing and feel so
wonderful
to me and so i also made this chart of
kind of the number
of unique contributors comparing 2018 to
the last year
we we ended up with quite a few more
unique contributors
last year because of two main events
these are the tidy verse developer days
which we did for the first time last
year but we're going to be continuing to
do them
a lot in the future so these uh happen
after our studio conf
after user that basically a chance to
get a bunch of people
interested in the tidal verse or
contributing to the tidy verse in a room
with helpers and you know we do
a bunch of pr's to fix a bunch of issues
you might also notice that there was a
big jump in kind of
may of 2018 uh i did a little
investigation to figure out what this
was this was actually me going into
a pr closing uh merging frenzy
in ggplot2 so there are a lot of pr's
that have just been sitting there so
we've got about like 20 new contributors
in one day because i merged all those
pr's
a few highlights of this year i think uh
really excited that we now have
a paper that you can cite if you want to
cite the entire tidy verse which you can
get
by using the citation function uh
the kind of idea of that paper is that
rather than having to cite every package
you might use individually there's just
like one place you can cite it's a
published article in the journal of open
source software
uh it's kind of i have to admit that i'm
like slightly
addicted to checking the citation count
like you know normally when you check
the citation count of a paper it like
changes
like maybe once every six months or
something but we've already had like 17
citations in uh the two months that's
been published which is
really really amazing also we introduced
embracing the double parentheses i'll
talk about that a little bit later but
part of our efforts to make kind of tidy
evaluation
easier and more approachable so you
don't have to learn about all the theory
in order to use it
the vectors package which is a bit of
a mystifying package in some ways
because if vectors
is successful in its goals you will
never know that it exists
and the goal of vectors really is just
to make things
work more consistently behind the scenes
so that when you use a function and one
package
you know your predictions about
functions and other packages are more
likely to be correct
that's the main impact for like data
scientists if you're a developer as well
it makes it much much easier to create
new types of
s3 vectors so if you have a new type of
thing
something that makes sense as a column
in the data frame vectors
provides a really nice set of tools for
this and if you want to learn more about
this you can
check out when when the when it comes
out jesse sadler gave a really nice
talk about how you can create new types
of vectors
using this package another really cool
package
which i think reflects some things
some sort of development processes some
coding practices that we'll see more of
in the future is the room package
vroom is a really really fast way of
getting data off disk from csv files or
tsv files or whatever
into r i think there are two things
that are particularly interesting about
it the first is that it makes
uh heavy use of c plus plus 11 behind
the scenes
this is kind of our first major use of c
plus plus 11 and the tidy verse because
we've been a little bit worried about
whether enough people can use c plus
plus 11
even though it is eight years after nine
years after 2011.
but the main advantage here is it gives
us really easy access
to multi-threaded computation so vroom
will use
many or if not all of the cores
available in your computer to speed up
data ingest
the other thing that's really
interesting about vroom is it makes
extensive use of this new technology in
base r called alt rep which allows us
basically to
laserly load the data in
the file so that if you're working with
a very large data set room is only going
to read in the data that you actually
touch so if you read in like a 10
gigabyte file but you only look at like
one column
or a small set of rows it's only going
to read that data up into memory which
of course you know makes things much
faster and saves memory
and then last but certainly not least i
think another big thing
that's been happening this year is uh
max and davis has been working on
tidy models a collection of packages to
bring modeling into the tidy verse
i think that's really coming up to speed
uh this year
with julia's joining that team and i
think next year that's really
people are already using tidy models
effectively but i think in the next year
that's really going to become a killer
set of tools
a few things to look for that i'm kind
of excited about for 2020
i don't want to make any predictions
that uh turn out to be famously wrong
uh i will not be declaring that 2020 is
the year of anything
unless i want to kill that thing but a
few things that i'm excited about
we've been putting a bunch of work under
d-player 1.0
this is kind of one of the projects this
is one of the first times we've done
sort of like a full court press so like
there's been four or five people
from my team working on this in various
ways
completely new implementation which
makes it much much better easier to add
new features
and it's going to provide a really
really solid base
for future extensions also working on
adding more problem oriented
documentation
i think we've always had pretty good uh
decent tutorials and reference
implementation we're also working now
more on more documentation that helps
you solve specific problems
we're also going to see kind of less per
i think or the the you can
if you're teaching like an intro data
science course you were to teach
per much much later as we provide
tools to kind of eliminate the use of
per for some of the most important uses
so vroom for example allows you to slurp
up
a entire directory of csv files in a
single call
tidyr has new functions for uh
rectangling
complicated or deeply nested json data
uh and d player is going to be bringing
back the
row wise verb so this should be mini
lists many list times that you need to
use
per when you're doing data science still
like really really strongly believe in
per
and functional programming as a
programming toolkit
but you won't be forced to learn it just
to do data science
and then also really excited about
google sheets four we've got some
uh really uh great ideas i think for
making that even more flexible jenny is
working
hard on that and uh i am personally
really hopeful that we're gonna be able
to use that so google sheets will be our
primary kind of data source
for our studio conf next year which will
avoid
a bunch of problems that we had this
year with keeping data synchronized in
various places
so what i did really want to talk about
though is a little bit about uh tidy
evaluation because i think we
we did make some mistakes uh just uh
here's kind of a provocative question
that
someone asked a little while ago will
tidy eval
kill the tidy verse i'm pretty confident
the answer is no
[Music]
but just to get just to kind of if you
haven't seen tidy evaluation before this
is kind of the one of the challenges
of programming with functions from d
player
and ggplot2 for example is introducing
indirection
and these in d player and ggplot2
normally you provide the name of the
variable directly
but what do you do if you want
the user to supply the name of the
variable in a function
well previously we had this technique
where you did bang bang in quo
bang bang went and quite required that
you kind of learned about the theory
of quasi quotation and inquo made you
think about these complicated things
called closures
now we have a system called embracing
which
should allow you to solve like the vast
majority of problems along with a few
other techniques
which means that you don't have to learn
the theory if you don't want to
so we've also been working on lots of
articles to explain this
i think i have these up again at the end
if you want to grab them
but i wanted to talk about kind of the
mistakes
we made and i think the first mistake we
made is that this problem as a whole
was much much harder than we thought and
i know
there have been at least like five
points where i'm like yes we
finally understand how all of this
should work and uh
on every point i was wrong
except except for today and i'm
reasonably confident more confident than
i've ever been before
basically because we've been doing a
much better job i think of creating this
problem-oriented documentation
and we can see in that that we can solve
the problems that most people are having
i i think the other thing the other
mistake the next mistake we made
is the theory really is like beautiful
and elegant
it is i think pretty much unique amongst
programming languages because very few
programming languages
have like a combination of like first
class
environments and computing on the
language and this just adds like it's
sort of really interesting and i think
it's really cool
and leonel has worked on this a lot with
me thinks it's really cool
um but most other people do not think
it's really cool
so totally i think it's totally still
worth it if you want to learn about the
theory because you want to learn more
about how these things worth
work but generally kind of the cost
benefit ratio if you're like a data sign
is just trying to solve some problem
the cost benefit for like spending the
time to learn the theory just just
wasn't there
and then i think we also ended up like
introducing too much
we wanted to be like precise and so we
ended up creating a lot of vocabulary
that um just ended up overwhelming
people
so i think two of our kind of takeaway
messages with this like i think one
one just being aware of the problem i
think
is important so that we are now kind of
more aware that there are things that
like we get excited about
that are like really exciting to us but
we know like the risky r community are
not gonna be
very excited about them um so we're
gonna try
and uh make it more clear like what is
the status of various things that we're
working on is this something that we
think is really cool but it's pretty
experimental maybe it's going to change
radically
or is this something that's like we now
have kind of grave doubts about and
maybe it's on its way out in the future
and sort of and think about how can we
get feedback on ideas that need more
feedback
without forcing like everyone to have to
think about those issues
and one of the ways we're doing that is
trying to be more clear
about where functions live
in the kind of the life cycle of a
function so what is the life cycle of
function
uh well the the place where most
functions live is this kind of stable
life cycle like we
we're pretty confident like this is a
function
like it does what it says on the can
it's useful we don't think it's going to
change
majorly some functions like when we
introduce them we're like
seems like a good idea um i
you know i think like when i first
introduced the when we first started
introducing the pipe like i was like
well this seems like a really cool idea
but like no one's gonna understand how
it works
and it turns out like that doesn't
actually matter the pipe is useful
because it does something it allows you
to write
code in a really clear way it doesn't
actually matter that you don't
understand how it works you
you can still use it there are other
things that we
have kind of so sometimes you know we we
think we have a really good idea
uh and then later on we're like
[Music]
maybe that wasn't such a good idea and
so we're starting to label those
functions now with
questioning when we're not sure if those
functions are a good idea or not
now sometimes we will like think about
it more and they'll end up back in
stable
other times it'll be like oh okay we've
finally figured out a better way to
implement this function or a better way
to solve this problem
and those functions become superseded so
just to give you
kind of an example of this in deploy 1.0
there were two functions row wise and do
that a lot of people really liked that
we've been in questioning for a while
uh we kind of figured out like row wise
actually can go back to being stable i
figured out why i didn't like it and fix
that problem so it's stable again
uh do we've figured out a better way of
solving and so that becomes superseded
so superseded functions i'll talk about
a little bit more shortly
these are functions like we don't think
they're the best solution anymore but
they're not going away we've got like a
better approach but you don't need to
worry that if you're using these
functions
that we're going to yank the rug out
from under you uh
we're not going to the only time a
function is when we want to be clear
that a function is going away
we'll tell you it's deprecated and then
when eventually it gets removed all
together then it becomes defunct
so just to kind of contrast deprecated
and superseded
a little bit more clearly a deprecated
function
is like clearly on its way out
in the near future which kind of
probably means in the next year or two
you'll be warned when you use it so
whenever you use a deprecated function
you will get a warning currently you get
that warning like once per position
i think maybe that's not warning you
like quite enough
we don't want to warn you every time you
use it because if we warn you every time
you use it
it's basically just as annoying as like
taking the function away in the first
place
so we're still working on trying to get
that balance right like how how do we
like gently nudge you that maybe you
should be
moving away from this function without
like getting in your face all the time
uh so two examples of that like the
typical df
function and dply which is one way you
used to create
tibbles before we call them tibbles is
on its way out
uh another function is deeply um do
generally these these functions we don't
wanna we won't go from like it will try
unless it's like a very niche function
it will not go from stable
to deprecated immediately normally it
will go through a questioning phase
first just to make sure
you've got plenty of notice if we if
we're uncertain about something
now to contrast this um we're talking
about the superseded life cycle
we've we've also called this retired in
the past
my sort of thinking was like you know
when you retire you're not like actively
working anymore
but um you're still a productive member
of society
but when people heard that a function
was retired they're like oh they're
going to take it out back and shoot in
the head
[Music]
so we're changing the name to superseded
to make it clear that these are these
we think there's a better alternative
that an alternative that's like maybe
easier to use or faster or easy to learn
or more powerful or something
and we we think you should learn that
new approach
when you've got some free time so these
superseded functions they're not going
anywhere they're going to hang around
for a long time but they're not going to
get
any new features and they'll only
receive like really critical bug fixes
so really good example of this spread
and gather and reshape
and tidy up you know like you know
they've been around for a long time
hundreds of thousands of people rely on
them we think we've got a better
approach with pivot longer and pivot
wider
an approach that hopefully you can
actually remember how to use
but spread and gather are not going away
they will probably eventually go away
but that's and this case is spreading
together
probably at least five years away so we
do encourage you to switch we will
change them in our documentation in our
books so that you don't
that we don't teach them we don't advise
them but those functions will live on
for a long time
and then on the other end of the
spectrum we've got these experimental
functions
these are functions that like we have
played around with internally
and we think they're kind of interesting
or kind of cool but
we're not like 100 sure about them so
maybe they'll go away maybe they'll stay
we just don't know and so we kind of
want you
if you are adventurous
we want you to try these functions out
and like tell us like are these
functions do you love this function do
you hate this function like
what's going on so we can use that to
kind of inform our decisions but don't
use them in critical code like they may
get removed in the future
don't rely on them 100 um
but if they are useful to a lot of
people we will you know we'll keep them
around and hopefully remove that
experimental label
and really all of this is kind of in
service between this
tension like we want to give you a
stable foundation that you can build
upon and rely upon
but at the same time like just because
design is fundamentally iterative
we know we can't get it right the first
time and sometimes
we want to be able to have a go at it a
few times
before we are confident so we really
want to just make it clear
like where functions are on this so we
can continue to build the stable
foundation
while trying to get it right in the long
term
so just to finish up i think the big
messages here
tidy this seems to be doing pretty well
uh
lots more contributors really excited
about how the community is contributing
to the tidy verse
uh you know we messed up with tidy eval
but i think we've learned from it
and one of those things that we've
learned is that making it more clear
what the life cycle is will hopefully
make it easier for other people to know
like what's going on
thank you
thanks headley um we have time for a
couple of questions but if yours don't
get asked i'm sure
hadley's really easy to find and has
free time to ask him afterwards
um is vroom eventually replacing radar
yes so vroom will not replace reader so
much as rita will use this
room under the hood so in the long run
you would just use reader
and uh if it'll use the fast room code
that should hopefully happen
in the in the next year why less per
it's awesome yeah yeah
that's this is the statement um per yes
per
absolutely is awesome but i think one
thing we see when like teaching
newcomers to data science that there are
a few things
that just that you just want to be able
to deal with like that you've got a
directory full of csv files like that is
such a common problem
it's really nice to be able to deal with
that before teaching about like
functions or functional programming
or iteration and so for the the like the
most important
tools i think having some high level way
to express what you want
is a little bit easier like it's not
about it's not about like
not teaching per it's a lot it's about
like teaching per
kind of later in the curriculum so it's
still really really powerful
i still love perl like it's not going
away but we're not like
forcing quite as many people to use it
will there be a tidy verse solution to
interactive web graphics
gigi plot 3 question mark um
thomas and i are arguing about that
already so uh
maybe i i i like interactive graphics is
still something that's like very near
and dear to my heart
uh i think we now understand like some
of the data structures
understand how some of the how we could
fix some of the mistakes in ggplot2
but it just doesn't still feel to me
like quite like the
the bottleneck like the critical problem
that we need to solve next but
hopefully in the long term and then um
last one i think we have time for is
will room be faster than f read in data
table
of room is already faster than data
table for some circumstances basically
because it is
like it's fast because it's lazy it does
it doesn't do as much
work as data data tables are freed
if you don't have to work with all of
the data and the data set so if you go
to the room website
uh jim histor who's the author of room
put together a bunch of benchmarks you
can see
where it does better than you're freed
where it does worse than freed
well thank you so much hadley
thank you